[Music]
all right your stuff Sunday just got my
fresh cut short just had a good seminar
I'm proud of them you'll get into it
[Music]
first item for business Sunday is the
fact that you probably saw Venus Forbes
sign Braxton Miller is coming up weekend
Jalen reeves-maybin John Toth will be
finding new cities so if you're a brand
or you know a milkshake a restaurant
chain headphones any kind of brand
that's looking for product placements
and social or creative from football
players braxton obviously Ohio is the
king of that Texas where it plays it at
what the Houston Texans Jalen and
Tennessee John and Kentucky and now
their new cities next weekend if you're
a brand that wants to do really
interesting creative with NFL players
please hit me up is that Sunday email
will get to you we're doing a ton of
stuff with these guys when you clean
stuff to my song and daily be a week ago
we're excited that ol oh we're just
talking about when I beat Jordan and
Mike in basketball
it feels good sorry Mike the gut anyway
what else we'll talk Vayner beta gabe
anderson running a department in our in
our office that is really exploding at
vaynermedia we were not walking working
with small and medium-sized businesses
for for the last two or three years but
now we finally figured out how to have a
product that's about $35,000 a month
25,000 and be for strategy creative
account all the creative video pictures
that are put out in 10,000 ad so if
you're a small medium-sized business 35
K month finally being able to work with
vaynermedia after being the kind of
brands that had to spend millions to be
with us has been excited exciting now
we've been able to do it for a couple
months I feel confident saying it to my
community so that's another biz dev
opportunity if if your service or
provider for small businesses for social
or things of that nature are hitting us
up for that but way more importantly if
you want to be one of those first
clients in that system hit us up on that
same note Vayner experiences a new
division we're doing activations
lighting up brand activations at
Coachella the Kentucky Derby Super Bowl
CES
can things of that nature so if you are
an event organizer and want to do more
things with brands if you want to work
with banner experiences as us being the
exclusive provider for sponsorship or
create events at your conference hit us
up or if you're a brand that wants to
activate at these big conferences hit us
up Vayner experiences to the email down
below another thing that I want to focus
on is Instagram QAS just are making a
video a day where you guys ask questions
and for 30 seconds in video form on your
Instagram then I'm going to take that
video chop it and answer it 30 seconds
and make a 1-minute video post on my
Instagram so if you want to be in the QA
put a scary b.i.g hashtags will put up
here somewhere in your post and I'll
take one a day and answer them on my
Instagram also we're looking for music
forum for daily be so if you've got a
friend or view or rolling with the music
sending our way down below hope you guys
have a great week great Monday
you